alors on se
la caméra numérotés sont salués la
planète mercure à tous vous êtes en
communication maintenant avec l'émission
de tam-tam canada dans le studio 93 ça
c'est la vérité le studio numéros et le
bon pour ça on n'a que deux caméras on à
la caméra numéro deux il est là est ce
qu'on peut faire un tel animal à 2 et là
on a trois caméras cette semaine mais
ses caméras là quechua à côté de toi
c'est le poteau qui est la personne qui
est un et skype 8 des voix
la personne qui est connecté qui est
branché sur quatre qui va qui va l'être
un dingue parce que c'est un fait avant
de faire d'inviter les gens à 36 tout
est une affaire de chiffres donc qui va
guider cette émission aujourd'hui c'est
notre thème sait déchiffrer les lettres
à des chiffres non pas parce qu'il ya
des gens l'émission en france chiffré
les allards flore passer à un autre
sujet d'accord ça va bien alors je
présente non non non spécialistes ici
nos deux responsables du web
léo gimeno bon jour en jour marie claude
simard bonjour jours méricourt dell
arrive un peu comme la souris après que
le gâteau est servi parce que elle
préparait l'arrivée de notre invité sur
ce cadre donc ça va bien ça va très bien
banques vont tester que c'est un invité
mystère vous douteriez d'accord vous
êtes même je pense au courant du thème
de l'émission aujourd'hui est ce
possible
donc vous ne dites rien on va se tourner
c'est par la grâce à votre expertise de
notre vidéo numéro un et on va demander
à léo et à marc montgomery de la section
anglaise de radio canada est un enjeu un
jour de deviner tous ensemble les gens
qui sont ici jouer avec nous quel est le
thème aujourd'hui de l'émission à partir
de ces images que l'on diffuse à
l'instant le média social
ça pourrait de ça mais ce n'est pas ça
les eaux les chiffres d'affaires les
hommes les plus riches du monde
ça pourrait être ça mais ce n'est pas ça
ok parce que la péta d'un maçon
mais tu peux plus d'argent que nous là
mais adrien thème ''la away celle là
quand même
le commerce a pesé sur une bonne piste
là je vous dis ouah marc vit sa voix ça
c'est votre nom monsieur raymond voillat
et tim hortons
c'est sa sé ta nou sé ta nou si c'est
donc une créée à plusieurs années en
1958 je pense que maintenant ça
appartient chose à au président quelle
était la dernière image ça concernait
quoi la dernière toutes dernières images
je finis se passer vous n'avez pas
deviné
[Musique]
alala a coûté c'est le commerce vu huy
mais ce dialogue sera servi mais c'est
le les marques de commerce les plus
grandes marques de commerce et marques
en tant que l'état
oui vous pensez si vous avez confiance
dans les marques de business c'est ça
c'est lié la confiance que l'on porte
dans ses marques
les marques les plus appréciées des
canadiens alors vous les avez vues dans
lovely voir dans l'ordre du numéro 1 au
numéro 10 on repose la vidéo
oui c'est le dernier sondage effectué
par la firme de sondage ipsos
ça fait six ans qu'ils font ça plus
populaires alors vous avez bien sûr
gogol
c'est dommage qu'on puisse pas accélérer
la vidéo parce qu'on les connaît tous
maintenant mais google facebook
microsoft apple amazon et youtube
wal mart visa visa qui est en baisse de
deux positions et tim hortons en baisse
d'une position et cybit si c'était la
deuxième image
or donc notre cousin anglais qui est
dans le top 10 au canada des marques de
commerce les plus appréciés moi ça m'a
surpris d'y travailler ici on dit du
bien de ses missions mais pas dans tous
les coins du canada je le sais mais
c'est quand même en espérant que le
diffuseur national en bas de roi
ouais c'est vrai écoutez est-ce que vous
êtes prêts maintenant pour notre invité
mystère oui oui alors on appelle ses
parfums on va les prendre a appelé le
professeur stephen non professeur mac
des david qui qu'il y ait à au terme de
l'émission aujourd'hui la communication
skype s'effectue donc avec un bureau à
montréal
ça prend une éternité c'est quand même
essayé de joindre la lune normalement ça
marche
ouais aujourd'hui non c'est youtube et
facebook sur mac
le monsieur en question n'est pas en vue
la hutte un tollé avec lui quand il a
parlé je vais je l'appelais penser ça on
est payé pour ça nous quand tu as passé
bon écoute et par là que une donnée aux
webmestres est occupé à essayer de
remplir des missions
on va continuer à parler l'écouter il
sait quoi
on essaie avec la technologie moderne
skype et cetera g1 antiquités avec moi
on nettoie nos bureaux en fait cinq fois
par an au printemps je verrai si j'ai
trouvé ça dans mon pupitre combien
qu'est ce que c'est devinez qu'est ce
que c'est que c'est un passeport
non non c'est une
c'est un assez pour remplir les rapports
des coûts' à les ondes courtes
les auditeurs remplissez sa voix sans je
vous écoute sur assez bien sûr telles
bandes de fréquences 5 sur 5 et je vous
mets ça m'a l'air un peu technique
c'est une époque révolue quand même les
ondes courtes c'est quelque chose que
nous avons envoyé en ira pour les gens
si tu remplis ça puis une fois remplie
styliste inès ferme l'appui on voit ça
d'un passeport on reçoit deux autres si
hockey et ça remplit les émissions
trente ans plus tard
ouais ouais entité c'est pour mes pin où
vous avez envoyé aussi des quatre
réceptions jours s'il y avait des cadres
on appelle cela qu elle c'est ça ouais
ok faut commencer par le duo par
expliquer ce qu'est ou ceux qui étaient
des ondes courtes mais c'est ce que ça
fait
oui et on peut la voir sur au téléphone
notre invité c'est possible si tout est
possible aujourd'hui tout est possible
sauf les communications skype est ce que
vous pouvez par santé c'est quoi qui
nous avait mille gb quelque chose ici on
voyait venir tient un objet c'est comme
c'est bizarre c'est lié aux jeux
olympiques
ah oui oui dès que je remporte une
médaille d'or ça va s'allumer j'attends
un peu 30
j'attends puisqu'elle sports d'hiver
vous aimez les plus en attendant
patinage de vitesse ok oui nous allons
la longue
oui c'est ça j'aime ça quand on va on se
met dans les pattes un de l'autre il le
fait glisser qui est ou qui est très
courte là l'équipe
absolument j'ai déjà vu dia soient
rejetées comme le jusqu'à 1h30 du matin
parce que c'est là que la compétition il
s'est fait à bien bien le patinage
artistique incroyable comment ils
bougent ces gens là c'est extraordinaire
je n'ai jamais compris comment ils
puissent tourner comme ça rapidement
pendant plusieurs secondes sans
toutefois devenir tout d'abord y suivre
des cours de physique
c'est une affaire de physique parce que
où ces cintres il fût ce le fait de ne
pas sauter trop
ouais tu tombes de trois fois ici je
vais te j'hésite et nous hésitons à
faire le grand pas est ce que nous avons
un invité ou pas les temps avec très
très bien alors on va saluer nos très
vite et il est au téléphone
bonjour professeur écouter professeurs
nous allons chercher une image ou
concernant juge sûr qu'on va en trouver
une ou deux sur le web
le professeur donc marc david qui est
dit pas dit nous pas votre spécialité
mais dites nous à quelle université on
peut vous trouver dans quel
établissement l'université de sherbrooke
top on cherche on va avoir une belle
image ou deux de vous dans une seconde
ou deux je l'espère pour le moment vous
connaissez la tradition vous êtes
l'invité mystère et les gens ici un
studio à l'exception de deux sur quatre
vont vous pose que des questions
réponses et déterminer
qu'est ce que vous venez faire dans le
programme aujourd'hui dans l'émission
d'accord vous êtes prêt à londres marc
bonjour vous êtes lié avec le marketing
peut-être oui à prof de marketing de la
liste est tout à fait à moitié à moitié
j'espère que c'est la bonne mais c'est
david est ce que vous avez pris une
claque mais ça ressemble pas à ce que
j'ai dit qu'il était beau mais le geste
intime une citation provient non à
moitié-moitié marketing liées aussi avec
l'internet marketing web
oui directement oui créer un des champs
d'application vous avez c est ce que
vous avez en son son sont endormis oui
ça va se réveiller
est-ce que vous avez une entreprise qui
fait beaucoup d'argent l'internet n'ont
pas d'eau fait pas d'argent ils et
pourquoi non jacquelinet vous avez
qu'ils n'ont pas de médaille pour vous
aujourd'hui
n'avez vous pas que j'abandonne nous
avons donné un peu plus rapidement ne
feriez pas la tête les pics vous écoutez
n'ai pas fait ça en communication
marketing et r&d ces domaines de
spécialités s'est scellée marque de
commerce
les tiens un lien entre les deux
professeurs expliquez-nous spécialement
cadre des jeux olympiques de quoi y ait
de couy de quoi il s'agit il faut
comprendre que l'on est dans l'épique et
puis les grandes marques et très grands
commanditaires
désolé et à travers tout ça bien
évidemment les athlètes essaie de tirer
leur épingle du jeu en baissant de
travailler sur les médias sociaux
utiliser les médias sociaux pour ça
avoir leurs propres commentaires donc ça
amène des dynamites très très complexe
quatre fois c'est trop quatre ans et
parce que le reste de l'année
les athlètes doivent trouver beaucoup de
sous pour
et il leur entraînement leur entraîneur
logiquement iy626 et des compétitions
côte excessivement cher ils ont besoin
donc d'entreprises qui vont les
supporter tout au long de eller gormond
la muse de réduire d'emprunt idéalement
les olympiques dans les deux mécanismes
complexes dès le départ moi je vous
dirais qu'un athlète c'est pas
nécessairement un homme ou une femme
d'affaires pas du tout et en fait que
tant mieux s'ils le sont mais en fait
l'europe les grévistes d'avancer et
d'atteindre le sommet dans l'homme c'est
l'objectif des passionnés d action
extrêmement déterminée
ce sont des valeurs aussi plus
l'entreprise recherche veut aussi
lorsqu'on partait évidemment tout ce qui
est vitesse aux performances
d'entreprises qui veulent aussi partagé
s'associer à ce succès là donc les
athlètes doivent à travers tout ça
pouvoir donc généré à travers les médias
sociaux
un maximum d'abonnés pour aller y
intéresser des entreprises associées
avec avec eux et ça donc ça amène une
année complexe pourquoi vous l'avez
mentionné les les athlètes a priori ne
sont pas des gens data on aura en fait
on l'a on espère il s'entoure de gens
d'affaires incompétent mais dans le code
des communications c'est surtout
évidemment les médias sociaux lorsqu'on
travaille sur des plateformes le
plusieurs plateformes en même temps
qu'on veut montrer notre entraînement
les imans avec lesquels on travaille ici
de suite ça prend une création de
contenu parce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que les athlètes deviennent de
contenu et sens c'est bien intéressant
mais ça prend énormément de temps
ça prend aussi des connaissances de
référence dans des références des
connaissances sur cette technologie que
tous les autres tous les athlètes non ou
si peu alors le fait social et
professionnel des comme marketing ou du
numérique évidemment sa voile il est
grand temps pour se consacrer à leur
entraînement
priorité c'est l'entraînement est ce
qu'ils ont des agents qui s'occupent de
ça parce que des fois il est des
politiciens qui ont des comptes twitter
ainsi de suite elle s'est même pas les
politiciens qui fait les tweets c'est
l'équipe derrière eux qui font les
tweets dans leur nom ils éclatent sur le
jeu pour moi j'irai mais la bonne et on
commence tranquillement comme un jeune
athlète plus ou moins connus dans une
aile abonnés 4 heures à peu près ça mais
rapidement lorsqu'on veut vraiment
entretenir une communauté c'est pas
juste de diffuser d'informations ceux de
réponse et de ce fait presque en continu
entre de façon régulière emploie des
centaines de milliers d'abonnés
évidemment on ne peut plus gérer seul
d'après une équipe ça près de téléphoner
qu'il faut comprendre devez vous savez
très bien mais c'est 24h 24 lorsqu'on
disait on n'est plus dans des
compétitions internationales
maintenant encore il ya pour les yeux
doux au public décalage horaire mais il
faut entraîner rapidement répondre
rapidement que l'homme qu'ils ont pas
besoin de s'en faire là il ya une
nouvelle équipe disponible marie-claude
et léo vous allez vous porter volontaire
pour aider le parlement où je me laisse
un nom mais la question pour moi c'est à
20 il n'existait pas les réseaux sociaux
comment est ce qu'on fait c'est à 20
puis pour que comment est ce qu'on
commençait 10 ont apporté un valeur si
grain on met aux réseaux sociaux
la campagne publicitaire donc avec des
associations alain pécoud ou à
l'extérieur des arrivées qui coûtait
très cher on allait chercher un deux ou
trois athlètes ou peut-être une équipe
qui est est représentative souvent des
sports très connu le rock et aux autres
et puis les athlètes qui travaillaient
en fait je devrais dire dans des pentes
est plus méconnu
je pense à la luge
ou des sports comme ça en moins
populaire traditionnellement bien
évidemment ils étaient laissés pour
compte
parce que les grandes campagnes
publicitaires et monopolisaient
l'ensemble de cette diffusion là que les
médias sociaux c'est une démocratisation
des contenus et landes est capable
d'aller chercher 10 public et public
beaucoup plus sec plus précis sont
intéressés envers notre planète
il ne pouvait pas y avoir accès par
exemple parce que c'est les médias
traditionnels qui s'accaparent et un
vaincu de la fusion mais par contre les
médias sociaux comme ça bien que ça peut
promouvoir l'athlète il faut faire
beaucoup d'attention parce qu'on a vu
dans le passé que quelques mots mal
placé ou quelques extras szmal twitté ça
peut causer beaucoup de problèmes pour
la personne soit un athlète ou une
politiciens et il faut comprendre aussi
que un jeu dangereux pour une certaine
popularité de venir j'avais une
célébrité mais une personnalité publique
avec le temps sa demande
oui beaucoup de temps et il ya aussi le
fait négatif donc de tomber trop dans
les médias il négligé son entraînement
c'est arrivé dans le passé donc dix lacs
les petits qui revient d'un coup
esclaves leur propre image
malheureusement au détriment de leurs
performances sportives ont son encontre
l'année et beaucoup de talent de qualité
de cette détermination pour monter dans
des placements internationaux et on peut
défendre très très rapidement puis une
fois qu'on descend de dire non c'est
encore plus et donc il y a oui des
effets vraiment pressé pour aller
chercher des sous pour pouvoir mieux
s'entraîner avoir une belle qualité de
vie et on leur souhaite mais en étant il
ya le côté négatif ou l'effet pervers
donc de t'être un peu esclave de sa
propre personnalité ou celui de ripper
médiatique
mes professeurs on va vous laisser
descendre du podium
en première position mais on vous
remercie infiniment nous avoir apporté
ce qui est nouveau vraiment au niveau de
la recherche des capitaux pour nos
athlètes
puis on la bonne nouvelle c'est que et
que en s'y prenant différemment
aujourd'hui avec les nouveaux outils
notamment fonctionné à coup sûr on
arrive à son à son objectif atteindre
assez merci beaucoup professeurs comme
je vous en prie bonne journée c'était le
professeur marc des david spécialiste
des communications et du marketing à
l'université sherbrooke ça c'est un
centaine de kilomètres de montréal en
allant vers le saut vers la subvention
américaine vers l'est exactement pas
tout à fait mais il a peu à peu près
écoutez je ne sais pas si je vais vous
mettre un petit test en effet la semaine
dernière je n'étais pas concluants mais
un jeu parce qu'on voit des résultats
j'ai regardé bien ce qui va se passer
voici le test le premier qui trouve lève
la main je veux même que vous affichiez
ça sur l'ortie six possibles ici est là
pour construire tous témoins vous levez
la main et vous affichez en même temps
vous êtes capable d'une coordination
non non c'est un c'est un travail
d'athlète
je veux savoir je vais avoir le total
des médailles aux jeux olympiques en ce
moment je veux pas savoir que je peux
avoir votre opinion je vois leo vous
fait même pas la course
non mais 4e on était sans doute la
quatrième position et ennuyeux mais ça
va pas durer
en général on était là au troisième
position cette semaine c'était quelque
chose
vous avez trouvé ça sur le site de radio
moi j'ai été aussi sur le site de de
cibistes nos dix ans pour eux dans la
marque dans la situation des marques les
plus respectées par les apprécier des
canadiens c'est la vidéo numéro 2
vous voulez on va la regarder ensemble
vidéo 2 j'ai trouvé autre chose en ne
recherchant chercher le tableau des
médailles
je suis tombé sur ça on va la regarder
ensemble
la publicité concernant les olympiques
un concours qui tout à fait très beau
visuellement
donc vous avez eu ici en anglais si la
version anglaise c'est voyez c'est
entouré de du concours
alors j'ai la version française ici
c'est sûr cbi six affiches dans les deux
langues
je prends ton problème ils font ça et
donc vous pouvez jouer avec radio-canada
cbi ici en ce moment vous déterminer qui
est le gagnant
le règlement est assez sain mais vous
pouvez rapporter des biscuits oreo c'est
bon c'est un beau mariage entre la queue
dans la nuit entre est ce un sport
fantastique
voilà les doubles et le drôle de mariage
des fois je ne veux pas faire de
commentaire parce que puis c'est un
commanditaire cheveux noirs je peux pas
aller plus loin
mais de notre santé ont certainement vu
qu est ce que tu les lébous individu m'a
tuer des vis tu manges la crème et ans
se tue gâteau au chocolat
non on jette projet biscuits là est ce
que les gens font ça ailleurs qu'au
canada
bon je fais cela si vous êtes prêts
maintenant pour ça va fonctionner mardi
c'était quoi la soucoupe volante et si
ensuite vous voilà il faut fermer les
lumières
c'est vrai que ça l'air de quoi la
télévision c'est très bien lâche pas
capable de dire maple
alors oui c'est pour ajouter un peu de
l'atmosphère
oui l'atmosphère olympique c'est ça ça
va peut-être rester après les olympiques
ça coûte un milliard instauré à 16h30
non dans une dizaine d'heures on pourra
sortir ensemble et prendre un verre si
vous voulez mais pour le moment on est
au travail
voici la tranche numéro un autre trait 1
2 3 notre très populaire jeu
questionnaire remuez vous les ménages
combien vaut une médaille olympique une
médaille d'or en épée combien vaut une
médaille d'or olympique
l'objet en tant que tel seul qui est
offerte à ok pyongyang
ça veut dire combien d'argent ils
dépensent les comités olympiques pour
une médaille d'or en 9 259 comme ça sur
un total de 777 m
combien vaut mais est ce qu'ils achètent
en gros c'est une question des
réductions de prix
je sais pas 1200 dans la 1200 dollars
est ce que c'est vraiment un ordre il ya
six grammes d'or dans une médaille 186 g
c'était vraiment de là paris 4 mai des
chutes peut-être 750 dollars canadiens
en euros ça fait combien ça fait 450
vous avez la bonne réponse parce que les
gens qui tarde à répondre alors marque
ça peut pas la même réponse que j'allais
de l'année 500 s'approche mais c'est
trop tard ça compte partager quoi
exactement pour ça a coûté 5 % 5 pour ça
ça valait 10 % à la con des balkans en a
oui moi je n'en vois arrêter là ce
couple il ya des boutons pour vous
l'êtes responsable s'il vous plaît c'est
fait tranquille maintenant on arrête le
jeu fini fini les folies
maintenant on est prêt pour la suite de
cette grande aventure juger notre vue je
sais tu de notre vue non ça s'appelle
monsieur agents monsieur agents et c'est
un autre spécialiste des jeux olympiques
qui s'intéressent à la situation des
sportifs et pas seulement les jeux
d'hiver mais les jeux d'été qui se
monnayent un peu plus facilement
apparemment c'est plus facile d'aller
chercher des grandes sommes aux jeux
d'été parce qu'ils sont davantage couru
internationalement les cotes d'écouté
sont plus élevées c'est c'est c'est
comme ça pour tout ce qu'ils ont et puis
j'ai ya beaucoup plus de pays qui
participent bien su allier il ya des
pays qui participent toujours au jeu des
verts parce qu'ils ont peur des gens des
athlètes dans ces disciplines là à vous
rappeler à ce même poste la semaine
dernière un auditeur du cameroun qui
disait qu'il s'intéressait pas aux jeux
d'hiver
parce que
dans toute leur histoire qu'un athlète
qui s'étaient présentés alors bon
c'était sans intéresser continue d'être
sans intérêt voici donc un spécialiste
de 2 comment augmenter la valeur de sa
de sa médaille on les côtes est
quelqu'un un problème auquel de nombreux
athlètes doivent faire face surtout des
sports qu une énorme visibilité tous les
quatre ans jeux olympiques mais qui en
dehors de ça faisait sport important cap
de compétition mais sont pas toujours
très visible comprendre qu'un
commanditaire ne sais pas si c'est pas
du bénévolat un commanditaire payé en
retour sur investissement qui a tendu
ses soit en retour dimanche donc de
visibilité et donc dans ce cas là par
exemple dans le cas de sport qui sont
très médiatisées tous les quatre ans
mais un peu moins dur durant leur
résidence et pas forcément mon
investissement ou un investissement
d'image et de fuite avec l'athlète est
là ce moment là on peut avoir des
contacts qui se lisent mais ça prend du
temps généralement donc qu'il faut il
vraiment 7/6 cet accord entre une aile
les valeurs de la tête et les valeurs
d'une compagnie ça prend du temps des
marchés ça prend du temps comme à
convaincre c'est pas toujours facile
pour ces athlètes n'avions pas d'argent
ou un agent mais c'est pas spécialisés
dans le justement le démarchage de
commanditaires et donc ça prend plus de
temps c'est beaucoup plus complexe
1 pour ces attaques semblent qu'ils sont
très bons un sport mais pas spécialisés
dans la recherche de commandites et donc
il pour trouver les bons mots les bons
intermédiaires la bonne manière de
parler ça demande du temps sa demande de
l'investissement
ces athlètes a pas touché si on a une
grande visibilité par exemple on gagne
une médaille aux jeux olympiques et on
parce qu'on va continuer il est bon de
100 tours et sedan se mettre à dos n'a
jamais prendre des gens qui sont
spécialisés dans certains domaines pour
justement aller lever un peu du
commanditaire aller parler à ses
commanditaires l' hiver expliqué
pour convaincre le commanditaire tient
une un accord de valeur on parle de
valeurs partagées on parle de dena city
en bandant et ça c'est un discours qui
se construit pourtant le vent une
compagnie leur dire mais je voulais vous
m'aidiez jusqu'aux jeux de rio
ça va coûter tant par année juste pour
tester cet accord là est ce encore une
fois c'est une peu de la spécialisation
et pour les athlètes sont des sports je
dirais un peu moins professionnaliser le
haut qu'il voit
comme il savait que si vous remportez
une médaille d'or certains pays ou deux
médailles d'argent et de bronze offre de
l'argent comptant alors alors gagnant ça
dépend des pays bien sûr avant de vous
montrer à quoi ça ressemble dans quel
pays vous devriez pour quel pays vous
devriez compétitionner je soupçonne la
russie c'est quelque chose je vais vous
poser la question c on est prêt pour
vous partez la machine
non non vous y venez vous êtes plus haut
à des longues et plus longue
voilà c'est prêt on ferme un peu le nom
tamisent la lumière très bien alors on
est prêt mais assez parfait l'eau doit
vous avouer que c'est la bonne
combinaison
c'est la deuxième manche et ça vaut 30 %
pour l'examen final
alors on est prêt voici la question au
canada chaque médaille
chaque médaille olympique a une certaine
valeur combien un athlète remporté il
automatiquement de la part du
gouvernement qui à fossa s'il remporte
mineur d'or combien cinq mille 5000 $
c'est quand même la canada changez votre
aucune de ces réponses on recommence
marck 0 et ben voyons c'est pas une
question truquée je gagne effectivement
quelque chose et ses 5000 d'appalaches à
5 à 2050 mille ok c'est beaucoup plus
que son papa ça c'est comme une bourse
bos pour aux arcs ça vaut plus que ça
moi je dirais 75 75 la bonne réponse
vous levez la main si vous pensez vous
êtes le plus proche de la bonne réponse
ça va être difficile ces vingt mille
j'avais 10 15 mai le tout à l'heure
alors non non vous êtes il ya personne
qui avait la bonne réponse voilà qui
gagne 66 et léo c'est vous je vais dire
cinquante mille 50 donc mais je pense
qu'avec un mille il était plus proche
ouais dans les félicitations vous
rapportez c'est comme ça comme les jeux
olympiques c'est juste je trichais
pouvait encore parfait esprit si vous
voulez vous insistez vous êtes d'accord
mais bien sûr donc 20 % 20 %
la première question c'est est divisée
vous pouvez pas cumuler donc pour les
auditeurs si au canada on gagne médaille
d'or gouvernement nous donne même une
pièce mais au québec révèle de là si
jamais ils vont vous toucheriez d'argent
est ce questionnaire un ses soixante
mille savais que ça je concevais pas
loin de la barre avant 6 et les pour 3
et à vouloir pas le premier à une
médaille d'or médaille d'argent et deux
de bronze vous gagnez 20 milles plus 15
buts +10 1000 ça fait combien 45 ans
d'enseignement mais c'est intéressant
qui continuent à donner de l'argent pour
chaque média et c'est vrai qu'ils font
ça seulement depuis d'or 2008 et y copie
les autres pays on va les voir comment
ça se passe des autres pays grâce à
notre vidéo valeur numéro 3 je donne
vide pas que ou de vigne et à l'avance
l'émission de ce qu'ils voient la voyez
les pays kazakhstan ils ont de l'argent
313 milles produits ma médaille d'or
lettonie italie il ya beaucoup ya oui la
mafia sont eux qui participent la russie
142000 suisse 111000 la france 84 1800
c'est en euros là bas donc il faut avant
dire ouf ou diviser les états unis 31000
le canada tout petit vingt mille mais
c'est loin d'être tous les pays qui font
ça
dans d'autres pays on offre
l'appartement avis gratuitement ouais un
crack corée du nord
si vous éviter la prison oui la monnaie
qui s'était pas encore énorme et en
chine si tu gagnes vraiment bien placé
pour avoir un poste dans l'arctique
ouais c'est ça la semaine dernière
émission la première émission sur les
jeux olympiques la semaine prochaine
également troisième émission sur les
jeux olympiques
bon écoute et est donc tout va bien un
peu je y aucun perdant à cette émission
doit on est prêtes la question la
question tam tam
marie-claude la fiche vous lisez pour
nous la question auquel crise lequel est
la grande marque elle locales
internationales dans laquelle vous avez
les plus de confiance ou que vous aimez
les plus et pourquoi est ce qu'on ferait
un tour de table bien la bonne réponse
mais ont déjà on a vu qu'elle était dans
l'ordre
moi j'ai j'aurais dit il ya quelques
mois google parce qu'elles n'ont pas
bonne réputation auprès de ses employés
tout ça mais on a vu un peu lisse qu'un
tel que une dernière main à un accord
donc j'ai traversé bisimwa j'arrêtais de
radio canada
ouais numéro un et moi c'est plus un
casse et radio canada international
il ya eu de limiter ou presque à peu
près d'un an m les marques de commerce
ça dépend avec qui tu fais affaire une
affaire de confiance et ça mais vu
google
moi j'ai pas eu de problèmes mais amazon
non plus moi j'achète beaucoup plus les
beaucoup de choses sur le web
by amazon situe à baton petit paquet qui
viennent acheter
ils te donnent l'argent les gens une
façon d'être et maintenir contente très
intéressant si c'est pour les affaires
comme ça mais jouissent et amazon c'est
c'est google c'est l'élève les choses
qu'ils n'utilisaient jours à jour je
pense
est ce que vous aimeriez ajouter quelque
chose ce qui est des marques qui vous
font peur dans laquelle n'avait pas
confiance
il ya des choses qui ont changé sûrs il
ya quelques années oui vous étiez en
faveur là ça vous fait un peu peur moi
je masse à volkswagen par exemple qu'il
ya un truc un peu cessé ses résultats de
ces pollutions
oui je sais quand on brise le contrat
avec le mais c'est ça c'est quand on est
fâché avec quelqu'un on fait moi j'ai
une voiture je n'ai pas dit de la marque
mais j'ai une problème je suis allé voir
le concessionnaire puis mondiale non
mais vous est arrivé mais trop tard mais
je suis encore en 46 ils ont fait un
travail
et puis ils ont pas régler les problèmes
puis maintenant ils m'ont dit bah c'est
à vous alors lancé marc la cie viens
j'aime beaucoup mon auto j'ai plus de
confiance tu vois ces cas par cas c'est
particulier c'est difficile de ramener
cette confiance aux fins de rétablir la
confiance avec le consommateur pour une
affaire d fois de quelques dizaines de
dollars
on espère pour toujours - je ne veux pas
le mentionner parce que j'aimerais bien
le faire mais je veux pas utiliser mon
poste pour démolir une entreprise bien
coté au canada non mais quand même par
le sable et les entreprises
téléphoniques car oui ça c'est une chose
qu'on aime pilkhana
des mains dans un moment comme ça sur un
problème avec ton téléphone d'apple il
t'est traitement tout change puis c'est
tout julie julie
dernièrement on l'a de 7,6 quandalle de
paix les compagnies qui fait ceux du
pain qu'on peut avoir du bon petit robot
on aime on aime certainement lapin le
monopole pour aussi le prix du passé il
ya même des grands organismes
humanitaires qui sont en ce moment sur
la sellette qui est un des grands
scandales spécifique belgique sans
frontières on apprenait dernièrement
même des entreprises comme village des
valeurs que donne on a l'impression
qu'on donne à la communauté ma réalité
cet abus très lucratif et puis le très
petit pourcentage qui est des organismes
a valu mais ça c'est une autre question
parce qu'on pense qu on fait affaire
avec une compagnie intel mais d'un fond
c'est une compagnie qui a été acheté par
un autre qui a été acheté par nos plus
beaux mâles font de faire affaire avec
une compagnie qui outre mer un quelque
part pas l'accompagner avec lesquels tu
penses tu fais affaire bien des
compagnies qui n'existe plus sears
mais quand on apprend à prat cool ce
qu'ils ont fait aux employés qui avaient
des pensions libre des bonis qu'on a
fait aux managers qui prenaient des
mauvaises décisions
on se dit ben j'ai bien fait de pas
acheter leur chose qu'ils aient fait non
j'exagère arrive demain mais vous
comprenez comme le sens c'est que de la
perte de confiance envers les compagnies
maintenant je pense qu'elle est il ya
plus de cars problème qui peut y en
avoir je sais pas moi ya 20 ans où c'est
parce que je vois le mans - en rose que
l'autre fois c'est quoi non mais on a on
a beaucoup on connait beaucoup plus sain
de comment ça marche
alors c'est pour ça que maintenant
peut-être on peut avoir ce genre oui non
je les moins sont beaucoup plus exposés
les marques et les entreprises en tant
que tel l'avant je connaissais pas
maintenant on peut savoir
on a des commentaires sur les réseaux
sociaux sont une telle compagnie on voit
comment ça marche la chose puis là tu
peux prendre si c'est à dire qui on est
beaucoup plus influencée pour les
réseaux sociaux pipeau tout ce qu'on
voit dans nos quotidiens
donc les choses qui m'a surpris c'est
dernièrement on a montré l'image de tim
hortons qui est de combiner des cafés et
beignets sixième dans la position des
marques les plus appréciées des
canadiens dans ce sondage effectué à la
fin de l'été dernier ah ok parce que
depuis deux ans perdiems est impliqué
dans un scandale forcément mais un
problème beaucoup avec le marché de
chantage auprès des japonais
on va baisser votre salaire on va
baisser vos avantages parce que on
oblige la province nous obligent à
augmenter votre salaire horaire minimum
donc vous allez payer la sphère la
facture et les politiciens disent en bas
côté certaines franchises dette et ouais
pas ce n'est pas tout
oui oui pendant l'ontario jet
appartenant à monsieur et madame chaque
chaque franchise appartient à quelqu'un
oui et pour avoir franchi il faut que ce
soit quand même millionnaire pour
acheter leur fils donc ce sont des
millionnaires qui ont imposé ces
conditions là comme vous travaillez pour
thème mais maintenant au lieu d'avoir un
café gratuit pour le lunch vous pouvez
vous allez payer votre café rien dit
mais voyons ces grains sûr il ya le
problème aussi des franchises
moi j'ai fait une franchise automobile
quand quincaillier au canada
épouvantable service dangereux pour la
santé la survie humaine nous sommes
toujours juste des détails fait pas
drôle et le bureau chef qui est pas
responsable on peut pas les obliger ces
les franchisés alors acte et si c'était
vous êtes responsable vous n'êtes pas
responsables et ils ont votre enseigne
c'est quoi l'histoire on se détache la
responsable c'est ça moi pour mon auto
mon concessionnaire me hébert
les papas canada va vous allez voir
puis-je appelle papa canada puis répond
jamais alors j'ai pas son nom qui
soumettent les problèmes parce que y'a
personne le concessionnaire mais sinon
la maison mère et un pompe au pied on se
trouve là au milieu ont donc on a isolé
le client ne l'empêchent d'atteindre la
cible c'est-à-dire le patron ainsi dans
son bureau parlons pas des patrons mais
quoi j'ai une histoire vous l'a compris
c'est que mon extrême un problème de
caméra
ok elle est allée voir la compagnie
dibala kamal habri zima flambant neuve
c'est ton problème
on veut rien savoir fait que moi j'ai
écrit un livre à partir de radio canada
non vous deviez pas faire ça non j'ai
dit la même chose qu'elle a dit je suis
simplement avec le courriel du canada
d'accord tout de suite ouais c'est ça
qu'on veut voir
j'ai déjà fait ça il ya des années et
c'est un j'habitais dans un édifice et
puis le propriétaire est parti à rire
dit si vous utilisez les lettres pour me
parler de leurs problèmes personnels
alors c'est la dernière fois que j'ai
utilisé mon adresse courriel ou mon
poste pour changer quoi que ce soit
parce que ça fonctionne et je pense que
j'évite de comptes de jeu quand les gens
me disent que ce que tu fais dans la vie
je n'impose jamais je veux pas je
préfère être un citoyen anonyme et me
défendre avec ce que j'ai mes outils
mais je dis ordinaire parce que je pense
que c'est pas loyal
c'est on était embauchés on a empêché de
faire une tâche précise pas pour essayer
de de gagner des avantages sans excès
mais une fois je traversais la frontière
états unis puis la personne tellement où
tout travail moi je dessine ici radio
canada la ville qu'est ce que tu fais là
ce juge journalistes web master puis m'a
dit ah c'est toi qui écrivent les choses
qui parlent mal d
non non non non non je mets des photos d
audio je découvre des choses que
j'écrive rien contre et voit sa vie
s'était comme option donc messieurs qui
l'on pose la question c'est pas moi qui
a dit bel et bien ils vous ont laissé
passer finalement rien là mais c'est une
situation très saine c'est vrai que
c'est stressant pce qui ont le pouvoir
qu ils peuvent refuser sans raison elle
a de fait pour comme 5 ans quelque chose
oui oui c'est l'aide et les
gardes-frontière frontières aux états
unis s'ils décident de fusées accès aux
états unis votre nom est dans une liste
dans l'aude et même sans motif sans
motif il n'est pas besoin de mentir en
fait ils peuvent vous dit les motifs
mais ils ont pas obligé à mettre ça dans
une papier gens réfugiés pour un motif
qui croyait que son fils à la liste de
confiance des marques de commerce le
rouble un security cette imposition 2000
au canada du 1500 à 2500 je travaille on
a une réponse par rapport à notre
question oui c'est à dire assez rentré
ce matin vous avez occupé à faire autre
chose c'est sûr pas l'émission je vais
vous donner le plaisir de lire qui veut
lire oui mais voilà bonjour les amis ma
marque préférée et coca cola
la raison est fort simple quand voyage
en autriche en allemagne ou en italie
pour nos vacances cela nous réconforte
cela réconforter les enfants et nous
aussi les plus grands de pouvoir goûter
à un produit familier qui garde la même
saveur peu importe où vous êtes
elle habite en france
étant adolescente mes parents m'avaient
forcé à passer tout un été dans le sud
de l'espagne un pays très peu développé
encore à cette époque et je me souviens
m'être procurer une énorme bouteille de
2 litres comme le goût sucré est
familier et familier m'avait fait
oublier par un show me cimon dépaysement
et mon mal du pays
aujourd'hui je n'ai plus vraiment de
marque préférée dans les colloques ou
les produits ou les autres produits je
me tourne je me tourne vers les produits
je la suite ici les produits sans nom
car nos revenus ont chuté
un vulgaire cola sans couleur sans sucre
et sans nom suffit bon ben j'espère vous
fait pas la même chose avec votre vin ça
va être triste année super chez vous
alors voilà écoutez et merci beaucoup
pour cette semaine qui était très très
cette émission mouvementée ouais c'est
ça et puis la semaine prochaine nous
allons parler j'espère qu'on va passer
jeu j'ai pensé un jeune boucher pas soit
fort je demande la permission mais le
thé de l'émission serait l'humour noir
au bras mais oui ça promet je me peux
pas donner plus de détails
je faut avoir un petit est mal un pic en
place par dessus pour finir on vous
voulez qu'on finisse dessus elle va
fermer complètement la lumière puis on
fait un fondu vers le noir nous offrir
ce résulat demandé à baba
[Musique]